o gato você pode estar trazendo ele dos
Estados Unidos tá na caixinha dele né de
transportar animais tá com cadeado PR
ninguém mexer foi ali tomar um lanche
voltou embarcou e esqueceu o gato no
aeroporto chegou em casa chorando meu
Deus do céu eu esqueci meu gato ô meu
Deus tu abre a porta o gato tá na tua
frente ó e ainda Costa pro cadeado da
caixinha O gato é muito autossuficiente
cara ele nem precisa de você não ele é
esperto ele consegue até te manipular
cara tu tá na cozinha cortando cebola
ele fica embaixo tá assim ó min D um min
um tu mostra para ele que é cebola ele
cheira fal assim ó hum não e sai ele
anda nos telhados nos muros tiver caco
de vidro no muro ele ainda mola as unhas
cara o cachorro no telhado ele morre ela
está banada ele não sabe onde ele bota o
pé o cachorro ele tá caminhando ele bota
o pu morre o gato manda na vida dele
cara ele nem precisa de tu não pode
prestar atenção que o gato ele fica em
casa quando tu sai de casa tu fecha a
porta se tu botar o ouvido na porta Tu
escuta ele dizer assim ó é graças a Deus
o cachorro qualquer coisa ele tem que
morder para saber o que é dá uma
cheiradinha lambe aperta o gato Ele já
sabe o que pode e o que que não pode ele
vem de nascença